[Musique]
voilà mon patron qui fait l'ouverture à
6 heures du matin comme d'habitude
marchande bull
bon je dois je suis fier mais c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique
il regarde vers du tout
mais bref
de france qui fait
j'ai choisi payen toujours moi qui paye
[Applaudissements]
petit
la japd mon collègue fils au gardien que
le patron
[Musique]
ce
la veille me tiens voilà l'espagnol
clients acharnée au flipper c'est son
gros travail du matin c'est de venir
faire le flipper à voile à raymonde la
femme de ménage
voilà ma malzac sénat patronne
[Musique]
qui
moi je voulais
[Musique]
ça y est on attaque le flipper
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
voilà me abdoul encore un comique
[Musique]
pourquoi pas chez lui seul un pm
c'est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rigole
allez
il y en a qui voient le petit qu'elle va
aussi un matin français de l'antigel je
veux bien croire
un café
l'événement de 1 300 points
[Musique]
bon
art éphémère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
café
chalus peur
malzac pas peur c'est clermont caramel
[Musique]
la pente est bien réagi alors tu peux
pas rien sur les affaires de leur bouche
samedi par l'ats et pourtant les huit
hommes et ça y va la vie un retour si je
mens pas
et comme moi
[Musique]
c
à 300 sur 120 gr
ouattara dans l'ex agent d'al qaïda
bonjour quand même toit chez nous
deuxième collègue le croissant 300
vous voulez
alors
awal à monsieur marcel c'est le gérant
du tabac
[Musique]
m
tiens y'avait beaucoup les problèmes est
toujours à l'heure
[Musique]
ont renversé
les 3 60-3 23 60
[Musique]
tiens voilà malzac juniors jean paul il
bougera ce faire il vous dira tout le
monde toujours bien polis tiens je crois
qu'on a un maistre a aujourd'hui
[Musique]
demeurez 2 degrés
achetez pas alors
[Musique]
c
je ne sais plus
je n'ai pas beaucoup alors si vous
gardez langue électro
[Musique]
charpy
bonjour c'est ainsi qu'apple
[Musique]
gino qui fait sa mise en place par le
midi
4la françoise cuisinière une petite
normande très sympa
ah enfin me voilà
on se prépare
attendez j'arrive le dernier comme
j'arrive pas à 10 heures le réveil est
toujours plus ou moins dures et voilà on
va attaquer
[Musique]
combien ça coûte merci
la petite lycéenne
[Musique]
pas possible
voilà
s'il te plaît
d'humour
[Musique]
ah la la
comment
est envahie autres
[Musique]
un petit voyage de la carte l'autre
c'est
[Musique]
chauffage coupé les doigts
il avait cédé
[Musique]
c
et la vénétie
on va bientôt à l'heure de musique mais
la visite là
ah oui c'est un représentant
[Musique]
et
pour les postes de commande c'est un
calvaire
[Musique]
et
vous n'avez pas des remous
m
[Musique]
cette facture
car nous voilà en train de préparer les
sandwichs et le simple pour le repas du
midi
ah les meilleurs moments de la journée
comme acheter aux courses jamais donné
de l'argent va france matin et alors
qu'est ce qui vous fait de votre argent
très exactement vous allez chercher un
studio que vous avez vous eu des choses
comme ça vous n'en saurez pas si je vais
en affamant je suis là c'est un studio
chez nous
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du service
même si j'ai figé
il est théoriquement tiges des boxers
théoriquement j'ai gardé secret
[Musique]
une réserve lambda
missoup l'est
toujours en pleine action
jean et madeleine aide à françoise
sans merci
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
non
madame ça merci je vais dire merci
rien quoi la pâté jambon surveiller tri
à face à l'euro ce jeune fille
[Musique]
elle dépend de délicats
[Applaudissements]
du passé bouclé à volonté du peuple
et touré
les assure la première l'atrix qui
doivent être en arrosage
[Rires]
1 quand alain
oumarou
c
réaction
bordés
[Musique]
ses patrons
il monte mais mon berger blanc
hier le quartier de saint nazaire en
sicile
augmenter messieurs les attentions
face à merci qu'est ce que tu me
on est passé par là et gentil
la fiente fils elle seule
suse et pavot et
un esprit assez tôt
j'ai toujours peur c'est de démouler sur
les clients
prenez
la verdure
je pense que je dois jouer s'assurant
qu'elles ont veillé
[Musique]
ma mission
les verres à whisky
s'il vous plait mr mousseline
mais bon
[Musique]
je perdais
tu vas y aller
la barge en retard alors est ce pas ça
47 40
et il est parti
[Musique]
pardon s'il vous plaît merci
je le fasse appliquer en face de ma
patronne
ses potes c'est moins cher mais c'est
pourront notamment des fois des belles
choses
un 2001
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas un engin de ce vent debout
en l'écrivant
moi j'adore passage à venir
c'est
je crois que le goncourt est passé là
c'est l'heure de la détente cas les
infirmières
[Musique]
là
moi je prends l'air un grand service
comme ça il faut prendre un peu d eau
on se base acte honteux pour boire
[Musique]
même jack
jacques
m
avec les reichel à compter à chaque
d'accord
m
je
[Musique]
mais mais mais mais pâtit j'en avais de
la mode il faut bien vendre la patience
là
avec un thé au lait s'il vous plaît
la société
[Musique]
j'ai quand même
vous regardez de hockey au fond regardez
blanc
lüthi 6e débuts
voilà j'ai bien travaillé
[Musique]
chercher longtemps
c'est pas difficile
on a été très remuant
voilà
alors je vais apprendre m'accrocher
bonjour docteur le docteur en télévision
l'evo 4g
alors
l'ag
j'ai demandé à voir
un franc succès nous a pour ce faire
les certificats rue
je viens de vous
qui veut pas le faire
d'accord ok qui veut pas vous le donnez
vous émouvoir et moi le groupe
scientifique
ok c'est pour ça je ça m'est arrivé hier
après-midi bêtement un chien il m'a
attrapée vêtements de normes évoluent
maintenant que ces mots et qu'il est ici
la poule et éprouvée oui s'ils n'avaient
que le fait que c'est lui je lui
demanderais ça et si jamais enfin je
pense pas que je fais
gurria c'est très agréable
on n'a plus du tout la nouvelle
angleterre et au canada
le rituel fatigué on apprend à voir
qu'est ce que c'est la gym
[Musique]
dépeinte dans le bâtiment
mais jacky sera sage on est accompli
après dix heures de travail votre
fatigue
[Musique]
les choses à l'égout
j'ai fait cinq heures et demie 6 heures
[Musique]
il pense
les ouvriers du chantier d'en face
à lacets qui détient
d'accord
merci à demeure voir tomber la nuit tu
arrives et encore deux ans a tiré du 100
m dos sans briller sur un an
j'avais imaginé pas loin de mettre la
cendrillon au club
sérieusement le pass pagnol qui ont mené
jean phlippe des lycéens achard me lever
le matin à l'ouverture vont devoir
presque la fermeture
[Musique]
et dès 8 heures c'est l'heure de la
fermeture je commence à me presser un
peu parce que ça fait savoir que la
journée est terminée se termine alors il
va pas dans les cours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si malzac aussi se prépare
c'est bon vous allez vous
et vous changer ses marques
bon ça va on était le tablier c'est bon
voilà changé enfin roger pour enlever la
cravate ça fait rien je la garde retirer
avec au moins 10 ans dans le schéma zac
à demain sinovac soirée bodega demain
et ça va on s'en tenait bon jusqu'à
demain matin sur
on a affaire avec des étrangers des fois
qu'ils devraient pour la première fois
et qu'ils nous prennent l'admiration
je me suis fait refaire photographiée
par les touristes étrangers
souvenirs souvenirs on avait clients qui
viennent qui sont assez dynamiques
comique qui arrive à nous faire rire à
nous comme nous aussi on arrive à
plaisanter avec eux c'est normal ça fait
partie du travail
il ya une façon de le faire voilà ce
qu'il ya beaucoup qui le font et qui le
font la dégoûter quoi quand on le fait
comme moi je les fais à l'âge de 14 ans
je trouvais pas pénible quand on aime
les jambes on peut arriver à faire ce
métier là si on n'aime pas les gens ont
peut pas ne pas suivre
[Musique]